The LD and ST instructions access main memory.
Note that its the same main memory that holds
the instructions, even though for drafting
convenience we show it has two separate boxes
in our datapath diagram.
In the form we show it here, main memory has
three ports:
two read ports for fetching instructions and
reading load data, and one write port used
by the ST instruction to write data into main
memory.
The address calculation is exactly the same
computation as performed by the ADDC instruction:
the contents of the RA register are added
to the sign-extended 16-bit literal from the
low-order 16 bits of the instruction.
So we'll simply reuse the existing datapath
hardware to compute the address.
For the LD instruction the output of the ALU
is routed to main memory as the address of
the location we wish to access.
After the memory's propagation delay, the
contents of the addressed location is returned
by the memory and we need to route that back
to the register file to be written into the
RC register.
The memory has two control signals: MOE (memory
output enable), which we set to 1 when we
want to read a value from the memory.
And MWE (memory write enable) which is set
to 1 when we want main memory to store the
value on its write data (WD) port into the
addressed memory location.
We need to add another MUX to select which
value to write back to the register file:
the output of the ALU or the data returning
from main memory.
We've used a 3-to-1 MUX and we'll see the
use for the other MUX input when we get to
the implementation of branches and jumps.
The two-bit WDSEL signal is used to select
the source of the write-back value.
Let's follow the flow of data when executing
the LD instruction.
The ALU operands are chosen just as they are
for the ADDC instruction and the ALU is requested
to perform an ADD operation.
The ALU result is connected to the address
port of main memory, who's control signals
are set for a read operation.
The WDSEL control signals are set to 2 to
route the returning data to the register file.
Execution of the ST instruction is very similar
to the execution of the LD instruction, with
one extra complication.
The value to be written to memory comes from
the RC register, but the RC instruction field
is not connected a register file read address.
Happily, the RB register address isn't being
used by the ST instruction since the second
ALU operand comes from the literal field.
So we'll use a MUX to enable the RC field
to be selected as the address for the register
file's second read port.
When the RA2SEL control signal is 0, the RB
field is selected as the address.
When RA2SEL is 1, the RC field is selected.
The output from the second read data port
is connected to the write data port of main
memory.
The ST instruction is the only instruction
that does not write a result into the register
file.
So the WERF control signal will be 0 when
executing ST.
Here's the flow of data when executing ST.
The operands are selected as for LD and the
ALU performs the address computation with
the result sent to main memory as the address.
Meanwhile the RC field is selected as the
address for the second register file read
port and the value from the RC register becomes
the write data for main memory.
By setting the MWR control signal to 1, the
main memory will write the WD data into the
selected memory location at the end of the
cycle.
The WERF control signal is set to zero since
we won't be writing a value into the register
file.
And, since we're not writing to the register
file, we don't care about the value for the
WDSEL signal.
Of course, the logic will need to supply some
value for WDSEL.
The "don't care" annotation is telling the
logic designer that she's welcome to supply
whatever value is most convenient.
This is particularly useful when using Karnaugh
maps to optimize the control logic, where
the value can be chosen as either 0 or 1,
whichever results in the best minimization
of the logic equations.main memory because
they are too large to fit into the 16-bit
literal field of an instruction.
In the example shown here, the compiled code
needs to load the constant 123456.
So it uses an LDR instruction that refers
to a nearby location C1: that has been initialized
with the required value.
Since this read-only constant is part of the
program, it makes sense to store it with the
instructions for the program, usually just
after the code for a procedure.
Note that we have to be careful to place the
storage location so that it won't be executed
as an instruction!
To route the output of the offset adder to
the main memory address port, we'll add ASEL
MUX so we can select either the RA register
value (when ASEL=0) or the output of the offset
adder (when ASEL=1) as the first ALU operand.
For LDR, ASEL will be 1, and we'll then ask
the ALU compute the Boolean operation "A",
i.e., the boolean function whose output is
just the value of the first operand.
This value then appears on the ALU output,
which is connected to the main memory address
port and the remainder of the execution proceeds
just like it did for LD.
This seems a bit complicated!
Mr. Blue has a good question:
why not just put the ASEL MUX on the wire
leading to the main memory address port and
bypass the ALU altogether?
The answer has to do with the amount of time
needed to compute the memory address.
If we moved the ASEL MUX here, the data flow
for LD and ST addresses would then pass through
two MUXes, the BSEL MUX and the ASEL MUX,
slowing down the arrival of the address by
a small amount.
This may not seem like a big deal, but the
additional time would have to be added the
clock period, thus slowing down every instruction
by a little bit.
When executing billions of instructions, a
little extra time on each instruction really
impacts the overall performance of the processor.
By placing the ASEL MUX where we did, its
propagation delay overlaps that of the BSEL
MUX, so the increased functionality it provides
comes with no cost in performance.
Here's the data flow for the LDR instruction.
The output of the offset adder is routed through
the ASEL MUX to the ALU.
The ALU performs the Boolean computation "A"
and the result becomes the address for main
memory.
The returning data is routed through the WDSEL
MUX so it can be written into the RC register
at the end of the cycle.
The remaining control values are given their
usual default values.